the Atlantic magazine has outed Mitt
Romney for using a secret Twitter
account named Pierre de lek Doh to
criticize president Trump as well as his
Republican colleagues in the Senate
meanwhile a man named RIA
who identifies as a woman files a hate
crime report against a pornographer
because he refused to have sex with him
after learning he isn't a woman we will
examine what Pierre Andrea tell us about
identity in the age of social media
Kanye turns right Liz Warren turns left
and CBS pushes AOC for VP all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Pierre de lecto we are all Pierre de
lecto in the age of social media you
know how much I hate being right you
know how much I hate saying I told you
so and just one day after describing
what an oily undignified politician Mitt
Romney is we find out this guy is using
a secret burner Twitter account named
Pierre de lecto to specifically
criticize all of his Republican Co
partisans all of his Republican
colleagues and the President of the
United States how do we know he's doing
this they found the Pierre de lecto
account mit romney was kind of alluding
to a secret twitter account they the
journalists went through and
cross-referenced the followers and and
figured out who this was how do we know
that Mitt Romney was using this to
attack his Republican colleagues well
here are just some of the tweets that
Pierre liked he didn't tweet a whole lot
he didn't follow a whole lot but what he
did do is like certain tweets he liked
one from the anonymous account Devon
Nunez his cow this was directed at Newt
Gingrich quote you were cheating on your
second wife with the woman who is now
your third wife even while impeaching
Clinton for cheating on his wife show
yourself out now obviously we know Mitt
Romney doesn't like Newt Gingrich they
ran against each other in 2012 for the
presidential nomination so it's not that
Mitt Romney or Pierre de lecto wrote
that tweet but he liked that tweet from
someone else here's another one from
Matthew Dowd who's an ex Republican and
an ABC News political analyst also liked
by Pierre de lecto watching Rudy
Giuliani's transition from America's
mayor to what he is today is like
watching how a villain comes to be in a
Batman movie this one from barb McQuaid
is an MSNBC analyst you noticing a theme
here all the mainstream media left-wing
news sources barb McQuaid quote this
can't be retweeted enough and what it
was was a retweet of Bill Kristol who
himself was tweeting at an old clip of
Lindsey Graham calling for Clinton's
impeachment in the 1990s and this was
being used as a case to impeach Donald
Trump Mitt Romney like that
Scott Conroy who is a podcaster he is a
podcast called black
I hadn't heard of him before Pierre de
lecto so Thank You Pierre for
introducing him to me he tweeted out I'm
not sure there's ever been a photo that
sums up a person's essence better than
this does and it was a photo of Marco
Rubio sitting in a tiny little chair
which was hilarious
then you had a tweet from ala pundit who
is great he's an anti Trump guy who
writes at hot air and he he tweeted out
even liked to tweet oh he rather liked a
tweet criticizing the fellow Utah
Senator Mike Lee for supporting troop
withdrawal from northern Syria that was
a tweet from allah pon de pierre de
lecto liked it why is this a big deal I
mean it's not really a big deal it just
proves everything I said about Mitt
Romney yesterday and I really like it
when news cycles prove me right within
like 20 hours of it the reason it
matters is not because Mitt Romney's
throwing some shade at his fellow
Republicans all politicians do that kind
of thing that's sort of what politics is
the reason it matters is that he's not
doing it honestly he's not he doesn't
have the guts to come out and actually
like these tweets or tweet these things
who say these things to people's faces
you know if this were president Trump he
would do it from his own Twitter account
that's really the big difference between
Mitt Romney and Donald Trump is not even
you know the use of Twitter and the use
of snark and the use of snide comments
it's just the Donald Trump owns up to
his and Mitt Romney doesn't Mitt
Romney's the one who's gonna like make a
little snide remark and then hide behind
a building before the guy comes and sees
what someone said Donald Trump would
have done it and he regularly does use
his own account with the verified check
mark and his own name in his own picture
to throw these kinds of insults
President Trump also has used sort of
fake personas before he he would got
made fun of a little while ago because
it came out that he was impersonating
his own publicist in the 1980s to get
himself more news articles President
Trump or a person who sounds a whole lot
like President Trump was pretending to
be a publicist named John Barron and
this is what he sounded like
in 1984 make up your own mind okay was
your first name
okay so that's obviously just Donald
okay look this Donald Trump guy is great
okay is one of the great people this
deals totally consolidated I write my
name is John Barron also president from
named his son Barron's he's got a kind
of fascination with this name anyway
again this is not even a knock on false
identities in the realm of politics in
the realm of show business in the realm
of theater people put on a lot of false
identities the question is what are you
using it for in the case of John Barron
the fictitious publicist Trump was using
it to build himself up build up his
brand in the case of peered Alecto Mitt
Romney was using it to vent his
frustration to tear down his colleagues
to tear down the president because he
didn't have the guts to do it publicly
himself it seems like a side news story
it seems like an unimportant news story
I think it actually tells us a lot about
identity in the age of social media
identity in this age that we're all
living in right now because speaking of
false identities you have a transgender
woman so a man who identifies as a woman
now filing a hate crime report against a
pornographer who he was working with
because the pornographer wanted to sleep
with him when he thought that he was a
she but then when he found out that he
is a he he didn't want to sleep with him
anymore and this apparently constitutes
a hate crime this has many layers of
identity but it tells us a lot about our
culture before we get to that I have got
to thank our friends over at first leaf
a new sponsor of the show so just that
alone would make
me love them and a new wine sponsor for
the show that that alone would make me
love them too but these guys are so
great the product is so terrific how you
get started and what makes first leaf
different from any other wine
subscription service is you go on and
you take a quiz and you take a quiz
about your tastes in wine and maybe you
don't know that much about wine so you
going but you you pick your flavors the
kind of tastes that you like the wines
you generally like you don't really need
to know anything to get started but if
you do have preferences you can put that
in there then they ship you six bottles
of one and you can try them out and and
you know I have to say these wines were
excellent especially the Reds I'm more
of a red wine guy anyway I don't I don't
particularly care for white wines but
the Reds were really really high quality
and you will not believe the prices that
they give you on them so you try them
out and then the key to the service is
you go on and you rate the wines because
especially if you like me I don't even
know I use wine language but I don't
really know the language that correlates
to my tastes so first leaf does that
work for you they go in and you rate the
wines and then the more and more you use
it the more the wines are tailored to
your taste palate it's really terrific
first leave sends out more than 17
thousand unique shipments of wine every
month is everyone's tastes are different
try first leaf today that is we're
buying great wine is made simple sign up
with my link you will get an exclusive
intro offer that is six bottles of wine
for 2995
it's an unbelievable deal and the wine
is really really good plus you get free
shipping go to try first leaf dot-com
slash Knowles canna wles that is six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping at try
first leaf comm slash Noel's canna wles
you won't regret it so you've got pierre
de lecto which is actually not the most
absurd false identity story of the day
because we have this transgender model
in britain who is suing a pornographer
because he won't have sex with him who
identifies as her the model is 25 years
old the the models name is rhea Cooper
and RIA Cooper was contacted by this
photographer who asked if she wanted to
appear in porn
and they're kind of flirting they're
going back and forth it's this highly
sexually charged conversation and then
the pornographer finds out that Rhea is
a man who looks like a woman and he went
back on the offer and the transgender
model said well why why don't you want
to work together anymore and he the
pornographer said well we can't sleep
together because you have a men he used
a vulgar term but to refer to male
genitalia Andrea the transgender model
was shocked and terribly offended by
this said that it was transphobic
behavior behavior and contacted the
Humberside police this was in the United
Kingdom and the police are actually
looking into the matter as a hate
incident how on earth does this happen
how does someone become so deluded that
you think that if you're a man and a man
doesn't want to have sex with you that
you're the victim of a hate crime well
RIA Cooper a while ago became Britain's
youngest person ever to transition RIA
Cooper is now 25 years old he
transitioned 10 years ago so he was 15
years old and some sick perverts were
preying on this fifteen-year-old boy and
told him to to transform his body and
take hormones and go through this
identity transition so that he could
appear to be a woman obviously this is
incredible medical malpractice there's
nothing rooted in science or medicine
here this is a social experiment that is
being conducted on a child not just one
child this is happening all throughout
the West so I I can sort of understand
why RIA Cooper is confused here but this
is lunacy where does it come from where
does this idea that we need to hide
behind these false identities come from
this is basically the inevitable
consequence of a selfish culture and
high-speed internet this is what happens
because on the internet you can go into
your own little corner in your own
little room where you can be whatever
you want to be in your own fantasies in
Mitt Romney's look MIT Romney he's a
really Stern dignified guy he's so
genial he's so nice he doesn't even
drink caffeine
he's as American Pie as they come until
he gets on his little troll Pierre de
lecto and then he's throwing stones at
Trump and he's making fun of newt
gingrich for having multiple wives and
he's going after Marco Rubio for being
little Marco I mean he's actually
hurling the same insults at Marco Rubio
that Donald Trump hurled at Marco Rubio
and then all of the genteel Republicans
like Mitt Romney say it's so awful for
Trump to say that Mitt Romney is doing
exactly the same thing he just doesn't
have the guts to come out and do it in
his own identity he has to do it behind
this little secret account Pierre de
lector that's the internet though you
can be whatever you want to be in your
own fantasies the things that some
people say on Twitter or in the comments
sections or or heinous I mean you know
you you anybody who has any sort of
public profile on the Internet close
your eyes and picture their email INBOX
and then then imagine it's 300 times
more disgusting 300 times more vicious
and wicked I mean just the death threats
and the awful wishes and these sort of
things that come in every day
look that's I'm not complaining about it
that's what the Internet is that's what
you sign up for but you do wonder if you
saw any of these people in person if
they actually had to stand behind their
own identity would any of them say these
things would any of them do this no of
course not even in the case of RIA
Cooper this transgender model in Britain
it it is identity under several layers
because it's a man who is trying to hide
behind this false identity of a woman
but the interaction that took place with
the pornographer also took place on
social media so you're another level
removed from an actual human interaction
I suspect I obviously don't know this
transgender model but I suspect if you
got to know him in real life and you
said listen I'm a man and I don't want
to sleep with you it's nothing against
you but you're a man and I I'm not
attracted to men and you know that's
kind of like one of the top reasons why
this isn't going to work out I suspect
he wouldn't run
file a police report but because there's
another level of removal from identity
this allows people to just indulge all
of their worst inclinations all of their
own delusions I mean this actually
speaking of pornography this is the
illusion of pornography in porn you can
live out any fantasy that you want this
is why it's so pervasive especially with
high speed internet because you you can
do whatever you want of you if you can
imagine it there's a porn for it okay
there was a liberal writer Kurt icon
Wald who he got caught he posted a
screenshot of something and then the
internet made fun of him because there
was a tab of tentacle porn which I have
not researched since that news story
came out and I don't want to research
but you know look there's a porn for
everything and I guess that's what he
was looking at anything you can imagine
there is some kind of titillating image
for on the Internet and so you can live
out that fantasy but what's the reality
the reality of porn is that you're alone
in a room with the blinds shut that's
the reality the illusion the fantasy of
this transgender model in the UK is that
he's this beautiful woman glamorous hot
all the men want to sleep with him but
the reality is he's a very very confused
man and statistically the reality is
he's much more likely to be depressed
and anxious and even suicidal right
those are all of the underlying
conditions that go along with this
gender dysphoria that's the reality of
it and the reality and the illusion are
very far apart on social media you can
anonymously attack anybody but in
reality you're just a coward
the illusion of Pierre de lecto is he's
this guy he's just throw he's thrown
whatever bombs he wants on social media
but what's the reality MIT Romney
getting his lunch eaten by Donald Trump
when they're at that little dinner and
Trump is smiling and MIT Romney is so
uncomfortably sucking up to him to try
to get any appointment in the
administration trying to be appointed
the the Secretary of State or trying to
get any other appointment that's the
realities this kind of Quisling weakling
and because we're uncomfortable with
that reality we want to live out these
fantasies online most of all what does
it tell us about identity in the age of
social media
it's all about you you the time 2006
Person of the Year you remember you and
so it becomes just about satisfying our
own appetites or feeding our own
appetites I'm not exactly defending this
British pornographer who is trying to
lure this 25 year old transgender model
into porn but at the very least what we
can say is reoccur the model who's
filing the police report isn't paying
attention to any other person is it all
he is concerned with is satisfying his
own ego to the point that now he wants
to criminalize it if you're a man and
you don't want to sleep with another man
it's all just about you even Mitt Romney
he goes and before the public and he's
got these preening and he's preaching
and he's moralizing and talking about
all the terrible things Trump does and
then he does exactly the same things
behind closed doors behind an anonymous
Twitter account but it's okay for Mitt
Romney cuz he wants to do them so it's
no big deal there's no issue here what's
the trouble with this the trouble with
this is feeding our appetites does not
satisfy us and listen decadence is
really fun okay you're talking to
someone who feeds a lot of his own
appetites but ultimately what you
realize is if you eat too much food you
feel sick if you drink too much booze
you get hungover
if you smoke too many cigars you COFF
the next day feeding your appetites it
you don't leave and say gosh I'm really
glad I glutted myself last night boy oh
boy what a good use of my time no of
course not this is true in all appetites
it's true in your your stomach it's true
sexually it's true even in other
ambitions that you have if they're just
feeding yourself
they don't satisfy you we are actually
and ironically only satisfied when we
serve others fantasy doesn't satisfy us
reality does you know we talked to that
trans ex transgender guy Peter Benjamin
on the show the other day and he said
what was so heartbreaking is he was so
excited to finally live in what had been
a very compelling fantasy for decades of
his life which is that he would become a
woman
then he became a woman and you had this
moment of euphoria and then he realized
he wasn't really a woman he had the
fantasy being lived out almost as
perfectly as possible but it was still a
fantasy it wasn't the reality and and
the difference between the two left him
really feeling Hollow I think this has a
lot to do with the skyrocketing rates of
depression and anxiety in this country
you know depression diagnoses are up in
this country about 33 percent among
Millennials they're up 45 percent rates
of suicide are way up aram unghh the
general population but over a 10-year
period 2006 to 2016 they're up 70
percent among white children 10 to 17
years old among black and other minority
children they're up seventy-seven
percent which is wild because black and
minority children kill themselves at a
lower rate than white children but
they're up even more among the minority
children this is not a single
demographic problem this is happening
across the culture what is that that's
that's not going to be just a racial
issue that's not going to be even just a
single age issue or a single geographic
area issue it would seem that it has a
lot to do with technology and you can
see people using technology at different
rates based on their age but it has to
do broadly with the culture this is
increasing rapidly it should be a
warning cry we do not want to be Pierre
de lecto Pierre de lector international
man of mystery Pierre de lecto is an
international man of misery you don't
want to be forcing your fantasies on
other people and criminalizing those who
don't want to have sex with you you
don't want to force your fantasies on
yourself either they won't satisfy you
either and what's so amazing about this
is you see somebody like Mitt Romney who
you expect to be the most prim and
proper put together stable guy you see
him hiding and sniping behind this
anonymous twitter account and then you
see a guy like Kanye West Kanye West who
embodies in many ways everything about
our technological post
modern narcissistic age and well Mitt
Romney is running in the direction of
that fantasy while Mitt Romney is
running in the direction of that
anonymity and those petty Snipes Kanye
West is running in exactly the other
direction he apparently nearly quit rap
when he had this conversion experience
to Christianity there is a friend of his
Adam Tyson who is the head pastor of the
Placer Rita Bible Church apparently
knows Kanye West and Kanye came to him
and said I don't even want to rap
anymore and Adam Tyson I guess talked
him out of that but that's how how
serious that's how profound Kanye's
conversion or reversion experience was
here is one time he told me that he
wasn't gonna rap I said why not he said
well that's the devil's music and I said
hey man rap is a genre that's right you
can rap for God yeah I think he was
already thinking about a little bit but
I just definitely said hey bro I think
you need to use your talents that God's
given you yeah and you step platform for
God Wow glad you said that he was
already thinking about it I'm not gonna
take any credit for that but I
definitely was pushing him hard in that
direction may in fact I asked him I'm
like a man of you heard to look ray yeah
he's like oh you heard a flame know
Tadashi no Tripoli no seven any of those
guys know I mean I'm sure he's heard out
them now I'm just gonna connect them
with some of those guys but he kind of
likes doing his own thing man he's like
he's like you know he just does what he
does and all I'm trying to do is how can
be really and grounded in God's Word now
probably that head pastor should have
just told him not to rap his rap is the
devil's music so he got he got that one
wrong but even if he didn't this guys he
sounds like a really nice like cool
pastor guy so whatever that's fine
hopefully Kanye's new album will be good
and could give glory to God and try to
elevate their culture in some way but
even Kanye's Kanye was right
I mean Kanye was right and this pastor
was largely wrong I think on the
question which is Kanye appears to be
experiencing a submission of the ego or
a restraining of the ego and for
somebody like Kanye West that's got to
be on the one hand kind of easy because
he's got ample ego to restrain but on
the other hand really hard he's the top
of the heap just like the biggest
celebrity in the world other than Donald
Trump and
so he's getting all of these plaudits
all of these accolades for anybody
that's very difficult and he's a hip-hop
star he's a rap star and rap is the most
boastful genre of music probably so it
is very difficult and yet he awoke to it
and he said oh none of this stuff is
making me happy yeah I'll just quit rap
music who cares that's actually the
right attitude now if he can reach more
people by rapping and sort of elevate
the culture like fine I guess that's
okay but I'm actually more with Canas
first impulse here I think that's I
think it's terrific that you had that
idea said oh yeah this is bad I'll do
something else that those are two
choices that we have in the culture and
it does come down to identity what it
comes down to is where you find your
identity when God is asked in the Bible
who are you he says I am that I am true
in the Old Testament true in the New
Testament Moses says to God who shall I
tell them you are and he says tell them
I am that I am Christ says in the in the
Gospels before Abraham was I am
I am the essence of being and sane
cultures root their identity in God it's
not even that difficult to understand
that concept because these things of
this world are fleeting if I root my if
I root my identity in having a podcast
and then someday I lose my podcast
I've lost my identity if I root my
identity in having nice nice bushy had a
brown hair and then one day I lose my
hair my hair turns gray I lose my
identity
if you root your identity in temporal
things you're gonna lose it eventually
if you root your identity and permanent
things you won't and the the permanent
thing the essence of being is God
himself so that's what you have to do
when you don't do that you are left with
a pathetic question the pathetic
question is who am i and this is why you
see people losing their mind in identity
politics because they're grasping for
something that's bigger than them
something that will give them some sort
of permanence and that might be racial
solidarity or sexual solidarity or class
solidarity but those things don't give
permanence either because even those are
social creatures even those are things
that change even those are things of
this world that will pass away very
difficult time to live in when Kanye
West has greater clarity about the
culture and about religion and about
identity itself than the 2012 Republican
nominee for president that's a very
difficult time for the culture when the
2012 Republican nominee for president
has more in common with a UK transgender
model than he does with with a sort of a
stable person the a very stable genius
you might say those are the times we
were living in though we've got to get
to the 2020 election because Liz Warren
who was running on the one hand to
moderate in recent weeks is now running
back to the left and the mainstream
media is following her the mainstream
media has a great idea
for the vice president if Bernie Sanders
is nominated by the Democratic Party and
all of this is having an effect on
president Trump though it's probably not
the effect that they want we'll get to
all of that in a second first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
and by the way what I have to plug is a
daily wire exclusive here the NBA season
is starting this week do you know what
that means
that means that the loudest the most
celebrated and the highest-paid leftists
say that it is their duty to defend
their freedom of speech by kneeling in
protest during our national anthem and
completely disrespecting our own country
meanwhile meanwhile they're going to
have to stand with the communist
government of China one of the worst
regimes in the history of the world and
which currently has about 3 million
people in concentration camps oh that's
pretty pretty pathetic isn't it that's
why you need to get your free Hong Kong
shirt today you can see it here it's
really cool-looking it says free Hong
Kong you can wear it out you can get
that today at the Daily wires store head
over to Daley wire.com click on the
store section at the top of the page I
guess that makes sense doesn't it and
that's the free Hong Kong shirt
go subscribe ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the and reclaim ensure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you test questions in
the mailbag which is coming up on
Thursday you
get everything you got another Kingdom
which is so fun this is the final season
of another Kingdom we talked about how
conservatives need to take over the
culture you gotta support conservatives
who are working in the culture you get
all of that and you get the leftist
here's tumblr and you are going to need
it because the latest from the 2020
campaign trail ain't looking good for
the left head on over to Daley wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
Liz Warren is making that same Mitt
Romney mistake
Liz Warren is making that same
wishy-washy I don't know what my
identity is mistake for much of her
career she was a pretty establishment
figure pretty normal pretty centrist
then she became a hard-charging leftist
in the late 2000s she was the
progressive champion then she well she
had a lot of identity issues by the way
because she pretended to be a Native
American for her entire career but
that's a story for another time I guess
the identity issues go down pretty deep
then in recent weeks
Liz Warren has tried to moderate a
little bit for instance she was at
during the Democratic presidential
debate Kamala Harris asked her if she
thinks Trump should be kicked off of
Twitter should one of the largest media
platforms in the world kick off the
President of the United States and Liz
Warren held herself back she said I
don't know that I'd go that far because
she knows that's not gonna win over any
voters in Peoria well Liz Warren is
going back to the left again she just
recently in a an impromptu press session
said that she would consider cutting off
aid to Israel if they don't surrender
and follow leftist policies says that he
is going to take Israel in a direction
of increasing settlements that does not
move us toward a two-state solution it
is the official policy of the United
States of America to support a two-state
solution and if Israel is moving in the
opposite direction then everything
everything is on the table everything's
on the table I'm a good progressive and
I hate Israel and I'll cut off aid to
Israel
why does Israel matter in all of this
Israel is a an obsession for the left
they hate Israel they hate it why do
they hate it because you've got a pretty
decently functioning liberal Western
democracy in the Middle East in a region
that is just characterized by sectarian
bloodshed and illegitimate governments
and totally foreign policies that we
don't we don't really like in the West
and then you've got Israel which is this
beacon of relative peace relative
stability lots of prosperity and the
left hates that they hates that because
it suggests maybe some cultures are more
conducive to flourishing than other
cultures they just hate Israel and so
it's it's not even that Liz Warren is
saying she might cut aid to a country
it's the United States can cut aid to
whatever country wants to
it's the singling out of Israel is a
pandering to the left and she's got a
pander to the left because she doesn't
know which way she's gonna go
is she gonna try to take the Biden
voters is she gonna try to take the
Bernie voters is she gonna try to be
Elizabeth Warren very moderate very
serious harvard law professor or is she
gonna try to be rah-rah class warrior
she just hasn't picked a lane and so
she's gonna blow with the wind she's
gonna blow like Mitt Romney blows with
the wind she's gonna blow like Joe Biden
blows with the wind here's just a little
exercise for you as to why this is a bad
idea
name the great moderates of history my
friend Patrick often the radio host
posted this on Twitter the other day
named the great moderates in history hmm
named the great moderates of the 20th
century when I think of the great
figures of the 20th century I've got
Ronald Reagan Winston Churchill
maybe Margaret Thatcher John Paul the
second none of those people were
moderate as people were pretty clear in
what they believed in what they were
fighting for
what about Lloyd George is anybody is he
gonna go down well inhibit Neville
Chamberlain does anybody aspire to be
Neville Chamberlain is he no those
squishes don't go down in history people
who are facing an identity crisis don't
go down in history who say one thing but
believe another and they're too timid to
really do what they want to do and those
people are forgotten those people have
made a big mistake if you stand in the
middle of the road you are going to get
hit by a truck
now the mainstream media understand this
that's why the mainstream media are just
running as far to the left as they
possibly can even if it means that they
disregard the Constitution most of them
probably haven't read the Constitution
in the first place you saw this when
recently Bernie Sanders was doing an
interview alongside Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez who just endorsed Bernie Sanders
for president and CBS News asks Bernie
and AOC if they would ever consider
running as a ticket if a OSI could
possibly be the vice presidential
candidate for Bernie Sanders in 2020
there's just one problem of course a OSI
is much too young to be his vice
president no matter
cBS persists anyway if you are the
nominee senator would you consider the
congresswoman as your running mate when
you are being lectured on the
Constitution by aoc you're in a bad
place you've you've gone down a bad path
AOC doesn't know very much about the
Constitution although I bet she sure
knows when she's eligible to run for
president I've got that you know she
might have only read the spark notes on
the Constitution but I'm pretty sure she
looked for that section and she's
correcting a CBS news here now this is
absurd for a few reasons
CBS News is a network news it's not even
just some cable network it's not it this
is supposed to be serious news these are
supposed to be objective people who at
least have once read the Constitution
they don't even realize that there is an
age requirement to be the president
they're being corrected on that by a 29
year old woman who was a bartender until
a year ago that shows you the state of
the mainstream media but also just the
absurdity of it all you've got a
socialist the furthest left prominent
politician in the entire United States
being asked if he would run with the
next for this left politician in the
United States does anybody think that
that ticket would get elected do you do
you understand the delusion
that is required to believe that Bernie
Sanders and AOC is a winning
presidential ticket that is a crazy idea
to typically tickets try to balance each
other out so you have Reagan right
Reagan's the rock-ribbed conservative
and yeah Bush Bush is the establishment
kind of liberal Republican figure and
they balance each other out you know in
2016 you have Hillary Clinton could be
the first woman president you have Tim
Kaine who could be the second woman
president that's not that's not nice I
didn't mean that it was an easy shot to
take and I took it but you do you have
an elite you have a woman you have a man
you have an older person you have a
younger person you have John McCain an
older man you have Sarah Palin a younger
woman John McCain a kind of liberal
Republican Sarah Palin the rock-ribbed
conservative you do have age and gender
differences with Bernie and aoc but they
think exactly the same thing AOC more or
less said that she got all of our ideas
to run for politics from Bernie Sanders
there's no balance to that at all
and if the mainstream media and the left
are gonna persist in believing that's
going to give them the White House they
are in for a rude awakening how do I
know that not from watching CNN not from
watching CBS but from looking at the
fundraising numbers President Trump is
enjoying this Democratic primary like no
one else
president Trump is enjoying this
impeachment inquiry like no one else the
news stories won't tell you that but
Trump is enjoying it because he's raking
in cash from all of this Trump and the
RNC which are now a joint venture have
raised more than three hundred million
dollars and the president alone of just
the president has 158 million dollars in
campaign cash on hand to start his
re-election bid that is more than any
other sitting president in history at
this point in the campaign now the flip
side to that is the Democrats
outraised Trump collectively all
together but you're talking about like
25 Democratic candidates collectively
they've outraised Trump even a lot of
Democratic strategists that were
pointing out that money is all gonna go
to cross purposes they're running a
primary campaign which Trump doesn't
need to do and they're going to spend
that money tearing each other down Joe
Biden who is theoretically the
front-runner is burning through his
campaign funds at a rate that is simply
too fast to sustain a general election
campaign he is spending 12% more than
he's taking in why is he spending it
because he knows his campaign might not
be long for this world she was trying to
burn that cash now to at least keep his
head above water is the minute that he
really falls down on those polls he's
over Joe Biden is spending 30% more than
the Liz Warren campaign and Liz Warren
is the one nipping at his heels
but even Warren is not fine on that
front because Warren is cutting herself
off from high-dollar donors and she's
refusing to appear at big money
fundraisers why is she doing that
because she's having this identity
crisis and she needs to figure out if
she's gonna be the big establishment
heir to Hillary Clinton or if she's
gonna be the heir to Bernie Sanders and
she's gonna be the small dollar
donations and she's gonna be a woman of
the people so she's gonna try to win
some fans among the Democratic primary
voters but it's gonna starve her
campaign of money that she needs and
what about Bernie Sanders he's the third
big person in that race Bernie Sanders
raises a lot of money he raises a lot of
small dollar donations Bernie has a
problem too though which is that one of
Bernie's biggest donors is the
Democratic billionaire Tom Steyer and
Tom Steyer is now running for president
himself so there goes Bernie's biggest
donor Trump enjoying all of this raising
a whole lot of cash we all remember how
the mainstream media got the 2016
election completely wrong so I'm very
skeptical of polls you know there was
that Fox News poll the other day came
out and showed the majority of Americans
support impeachment and removal from
office and I saw that poll and I said I
just don't believe that
and it wasn't wishful thinking I think I
have a pretty clear eye when it comes to
these things or I certainly try to have
a clear eye when it comes to these
things and I thought that just doesn't
sound right to me I don't think that
after three years of all these BS
attempts to overturn the 2016 election
that right now the majority of Americans
want to throw the president out of
office because he made a long-distance
phone call to Ukraine or something I
know anything about FIFA lie have any
idea what this non traversée is about
and it turned out that I was right later
came out that that poll grossly over
sampled Democrats so it's skewed the
poll very much in the favor of
impeachment and removal from office this
is why I'm much more interested in hard
dollars in tangible indicators of how
this elections going and that there
might be some red outlets there might be
some blue outlets but Green is of a
pretty reliable color and a lot of that
green most of that green is going to
President Trump right now I also need to
point out before we leave this topic of
identity this is not just affecting
politics this is not even just affecting
pop culture this is affecting
increasingly young people so the
transgender activists in or the
transgender model in the United Kingdom
was 15 years old when medical
malpractice iners and a confused culture
convinced him to live the rest of his
life as a woman and possibly make
permanent alterations to his body
because of them that's really bad but
it's going down and it's it's affecting
colleges and high schools and elementary
schools and all these sorts of things
Boise State Boise State University
hosted an event last week called
inclusive teaching means inclusive
grading - what is inclusive grading it
means that we are not not only are we
going to erase standards of truth and
reality from our curricula which has
been happening for decades now it's just
perspectives there's no truth that's
your truth and my truth but they're
gonna follow that idea to its logical
conclusion and erase standards from
grading as well this was not a one-off
workshop at Boise State the same event
was hosted at University of Tennessee
Knoxville this event was aimed to quote
engage instructor
in conversations and activities designed
to foreground diversity and inclusion in
considerations of assessment and grading
practices have you made your way
swimming through all that jargon yet
what it means is you're going to grade
different people not based on the
quality of their work but on the color
of their skin and on their sex and on
their sexual preferences there's a
similar event at American University
this is how the event at American
University billed itself how to assess
writing without judging its quality oh
my gosh how to assess without judging
you can't you can't assess without
judging to make an assessment is to make
a judgment what do you make judgments on
quality this workshop warned that quote
the practices of grading writing
maintained white language supremacy that
to use correct language is racist
somehow another workshop was called why
are you reacting that way and it
promised to quote give participants
opportunities to examine the lens they
use to interact with others and
understand why there is resistance what
this means is it was going to teach
teachers not how to deal with bad
students who were disrupting class and
causing problems but to teach teachers
not to discipline those students just to
learn from them and when the student
acts up realize that it's probably your
fault and to figure out what you can
learn from the student that way
everything about this is backwards and
everything about this comes from the
exact same identity crisis that affects
Rhea Cooper and Pierre de lecto and all
the rest of us in the mimimi social
media era all the rest of us in the era
of being one and all the time magazine
Person of the Year
what with the writing quality writing
expresses and reflects your thoughts to
write well as to think clearly which is
why it's so hard that's what the great
historian and writer David McCulloch
said writing as a reflection of the
brain Dennis Prager says that
writing is the way that we communicate
with one another and the only way that
we can communicate with one another is
if there is an objective reality outside
of us outside of me me me a an identity
crisis society a society that is totally
obsessed with the self can never admit
that that objective reality it can't
admit to grades it can't admit to
writing standards it can't admit to
grammar and can't admit to any of that
because that would contradict the self
so if you are really bad at writing and
you put out some bad writing it couldn't
possibly be that you're bad at writing
the premise is I'm perfect at everything
and all of my desires must be satisfied
so then the only other option is writing
itself has is not objective it couldn't
possibly be that you got a bad grade
because you're a little slow or you
didn't do the work or you're a little
bit lazy or you stayed up too late going
to a party couldn't be that it's that
the work itself can't be objective or
that the teacher is missing something
can't be that you acted up because
you're poorly raised and badly behaved
and you have no discipline couldn't be
that it could be it's the teachers fault
it's always somebody else's fault that
way lies misery that identity crisis
lies misery it comes right down to the
central problem of preferring fantasy to
reality to preferring the indulgence of
our own appetites to the satisfaction of
eternal longings bigger longings than
ourselves and it comes down to the
identity question who are you in a sane
society it's the simplest question in
the world in a in a society that's lost
its way that's lost its mooring it's the
most pitiful question that few people if
any can answer that's our show I hope
you can answer that show I don't have
much of an identity crisis I know that I
am Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show get your mailbag
questions in for Thursday I'm heading
over to the University of Florida at
Gainesville so we're gonna be doing a
speech there for the rest of my after
and we'll be talking about even more
uncomfortable truths in this culture of
fantasy see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]